Why don't you give it a try?
Well, I'm willing to
try anything.
[Music]
I
feel like this is pretty good, but
you also write passionately,
right? This is just my opinion.  But do you
think that the first action is an art that places the most importance on the heart?
In a world where it is impossible to redo just one stroke,
what you want to express from the heart, concentrating with all your might on a moment, passes through your arm, through the tool of a brush, and then
as letters on your hair.  The
words that capture that momentary flickering that appear
can even more be called the heart [Music] That's right. That's right. If you're going to
let your heart out, then if you
go with this image, maybe you'll be back.
Thank you both for today.
till